everyone likes to think they're not
affected by advertisements but unless
you've never seen a single advertisement
in your life your choices are influenced
and affected by all the advertisements
you've ever seen every advertisement
changes an opinion on the brand or
product you may see some advertisements
where you think why would anyone decide
to buy this product after seeing this
but the purpose of advertisements is no
longer tether consumer immediately pick
up the phone and buy the product the
purpose of these advertisements is not
to inform the consumer about the product
and its features the reason companies
like McDonald's who have an almost
universal recognition still advertise is
because they are trying to build an
opinion and corresponding brand image in
their consumers minds there are two main
psychological methods that marketers use
nowadays for their advertisements the
first method is called the mere-exposure
method these are those minimalist
bare-bones advertisements that make you
scratch your head and wonder why the
company would spend thousands of dollars
on them it's because everyone is more
comfortable in groups if one line at the
bank is considerably longer than the
other people will almost always go to
the longer line because they think that
there must be a reason that people
choose one line over the other they
think that one line is better than the
other or one line is more correct than
the other it's just an easier and more
comfortable decision it's the same kind
of idea in consumer psychology by
exposing the consumer to the brand the
consumers start to feel like they know
it because of this when the consumer
goes to the store to buy detergent they
can reach riptide and be comfortable in
this decision the tide detergent might
be a couple dollars more in the store
brand detergent but they know that this
brand detergent will work well it
wouldn't be such a huge brand if it
didn't work so well
the greater example of this phenomenon
is with painkillers and other
over-the-counter drugs at the pharmacy
the generic brand drugs are the exact
same product as the name-brand with the
exact same composition of ingredients if
they had a different composition of
ingredients they would not be allowed to
be called the same drug advil generic
brand ibuprofen the exact same product
with the exact same composition but
still people will buy the advil
despite its deeper price it's just
easier to choose what everyone else
chooses the consumer tends to be anxious
to buy the cheaper generic frame drug
does this mean you should always buy the
generic brand drugs well not necessarily
in a study by the University of
Cincinnati Parkinson's disease patients
were given two drugs one in which they
were told is a more expensive name brand
drug the other being a less expensive
off-brand drug after taking the
supposedly more expensive drug the
patient's had a 20% greater increase and
motor skills then after having taken the
supposedly cheaper drug one reality both
the injections were just saving the
solution the expectations were higher
for the name red drug
therefore the patients felt better
because hope osebo effect
so sometimes spending more will make you
feel better
the other common psychological method
used in marketing is the classic
conditioning method the idea behind this
technique came from a study done by
Russian physiologist Ivonne Pavlov in
the 1890s Pavlov noticed that his dogs
would start to salivate whenever he
would enter the room even if he didn't
have food this was because the dogs had
an expectation that they would receive
food when Pavlov came into the room
because every time he did have food he
would walk into the room Pavlov decided
to start ringing a bell whenever he gave
food to his dogs and after a while the
dogs would whenever they heard the sound
of a bell start salivating this is
because the dogs were trained to
associate the sound of the Bell with
food coming they were trained to have
the expectation of food the same
psychological principle worked with
humans friends will try to have certain
feelings reactions or images associated
with their product if in their
advertisements they show certain images
in conjunction with their product the
consumer will subconsciously relate the
images to the product the best part of
this technique is that it always works
no matter how much you try to block out
the advertisements as long as you see
them you will start to subconsciously
relate the two images car brands are the
biggest culprit of using a sneaky
technique their advertisements rarely
have anything to do with the actual car
or rather about someone driving a car
luxury car brands will show people in
black tie pulling up to a red carpet
event while SUV advertisements will show
us an adventurous looking couple with
kayaks and bikes in tow driving on some
dirt road
at this point you're barely buying a car
but rather a lifestyle you're buying
into the image of being someone that
goes to black-tie events or spends their
weekend being adventurous the car barely
matters at that point it's an image that
you're buying perhaps the greatest
advertising success in recent memory is
the Beats headphones friend Pete's
controls 27 percent of the 140 billion
dollar headphone market despite making
would have generally agreed upon to be
mediocre selling headphones the New York
Times reported that the actual
manufacturing cost of these headphones
which sell for upwards of two hundred
and fifty dollars is about fourteen
dollars the reason beats are considered
such a premium product because of their
marketing and brand image from the
beginning he's spent a huge amount of
money to pay for celebrity sponsorships
all the most famous athletes were
wearing beast in their interviews so a
consumers start to get the idea that
these were fashion high priced
headphones the high price solid heavy
materials sturdy packaging and celebrity
endorsements all raised people's
expectations and likely psychologically
made the headphones sound better just
like with the name-brand medicines
you